la victoria de la derecha en las
elecciones constituyentes de chile será
clave a la hora de redactar la nueva
constitución del país pues muchos de los
nuevos consejeros encargados de
presentar este nuevo borrador se
inclinan contra derechos Como el aborto
y otros derechos sexuales y
reproductivos Este es el tema que
discutimos con nuestro segundo invitado
de hoy Jorge contece constitucionalista
doctor en derecho por la universidad de
Yale y a quien saludamos en Santiago de
Chile Muchísimas gracias señor con todo
ese Buen día para usted muy buen día
para ustedes también mire según el
diario la tercera un gran número de los
nuevos representantes no estaba de
acuerdo con la anterior propuesta
constitucional que fue rechazada el año
pasado es decir ni siquiera querían
llevar la votación pero ahora ellos
mismos son los encargados de hacer un
nuevo borrador Qué grandes cambios
podremos ver en esta nueva propuesta
O sea no solo no estaban a favor de la
propuesta que se votó el año pasado el
partido republicano que es el partido
que ha obtenido la primera mayoría a
nivel nacional y que junto con los
representantes de la derecha van a poder
tener algo impensado que es el poder de
Beto respecto de la comisión experta que
tiene que proponer al consejo
constitucional el borrador de propuesta
de nueva constitución partido
republicano se ha puesto desde el primer
día al cambio de la Constitución para el
partido republicano la Constitución
actual de 1980 dictada por el por la
dictadura militar de Augusto pinochet
está bien y por lo tanto hay
efectivamente hay una paradoja
importantísima que es aquel grupo que
desde el día uno estuvo en contra del
cambio constitucional y en esta última
iteración del proceso no firmó el
acuerdo que permitió este tercer intento
de cambio es hoy día su principal
protagonista
bueno es que tienen en sus manos los
derechos humanos y los derechos civiles
de todos los ciudadanos por eso le
quiero preguntar sobre la Constitución
actual de chile que permite por ejemplo
el aborto bajo ciertas causales y los
nuevos consejeros han dicho que le
apuestan a resguardar el llamado derecho
a la vida cómo pueden Entonces los que
ahora son grupos minoritarios y otros
actores sociales proteger esto por lo
que tanto han luchado y que fue uno de
los puntos principales de las
manifestaciones los derechos sexuales y
reproductivos de las mujeres Claro
porque como tú probablemente sabes chile
hasta hace muy poco no tenía ninguna
causal en que se permitía la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
recién en 2017 se aprueba una ley que
permite en tres causales específicas
ello con la oposición de la derecha que
llevó el proyecto el tribunal
constitucional finalmente el tribunal
constitucional aprobó ello qué Creo yo
que hay que mirar acá lo que estamos
viendo en Chile es una suerte de
política constitucional pendular es
decir la propuesta que se rechazó en
septiembre del 2022 en materia de
derechos sexuales y reproductivos era
muy avanzada era tan avanzada que para
algunos sectores significó una línea
Roja
en digamos al momento en que se aprueban
las normas sobre derechos sexuales y
reproductivos incluyendo la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo en la
Constitución que hoy día lo que tenemos
es una respuesta completamente en 180
grados es decir a estas personas que van
a ser mayoría en el consejo
constitucional diciendo no pensamos que
esto deba estar en la constitución
Qué puede pasar acá efectivamente va a
haber que ver cómo es que se producen
las conversaciones entre los distintos
grupos dentro tanto de la comisión
experta como posteriormente el consejo
constitucional y lo que hay que pensar
es que se abren o no posibilidades de la
interpretación constitucional la
Constitución vigente no contempla
ninguna Norma sobre interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo sobre aborto
tiene una norma que protege la vida del
que está por nacer en que la
Constitución le da un mandato a la ley
para que la ley proteja la vida que está
por hacer y aún así con estas normas el
aborto en Chile existe como digo en tres
causales específicas si quedáramos con
algo parecido a eso Entonces todavía es
posible que a nivel legal no
constitucional que a nivel de las leyes
puedan existir causales para la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
para el aborto para el reconocimiento de
los derechos sexuales reproductivos si
no ocurre ello y se Avanza en una
constitucionalización
prohibición del aborto entonces
efectivamente lo que vamos a ver es un
serio retroceso que es lo que algunas
personas digamos plausiblemente esperan
que pueda suceder muy plausiblemente
además y ahí le pregunto Pues en la
práctica qué margen de acción van a
tener los aliados de boric o los Aliados
del cambio constitucional en este
momento en este momento ese margen para
ser Franco creo que se ha reducido
notoriamente es decir tú tienes un
consejo constitucional como digo las
reglas con las que se ha diseñado este
proceso son difíciles de explicar en una
entrevista corta pero que habría que
decir es la manera como se pensó este
intento que llevamos hablando en 2023 es
que fueron proceso Por así decirlo
contenido es un proceso que está lleno
de bordes Verdad que es lo contrario lo
que sucedió en 2022 en que se desbordó
entonces lo que podría suceder ahí es
que se Avanza en una en una propuesta de
Norma institucional
que elimine completamente la prohibición
Perdón la la posibilidad del aborto y
entonces algún sector dentro de la
comisión experta o del Consejo
constitucional tendrá que requerir al
tercer órgano que participa este proceso
que es un comité técnico de
admisibilidad básicamente un panel de
árbitros este panel de árbitros lo que
hace es velar porque las bases que son
Por así decirlo los Marcos donde debe
jugarse el partido constitucional se
respeten si ese comité técnico de
admisibilidad considerara que una norma
que prohibiera completamente el aborto
introducción voluntaria del embarazo no
respeta las bases entonces ahí se abre
una posibilidad para que algo así no
prospere pero como digo todo esto como
tú bien como tú puedes ver está lleno de
Pequeños obstáculos que hacen que sea un
proceso muy contenido con poco espacio
para la participación con poco espacio
para la para la deliberación
y con poco espacio al parecer para la
diversidad mire Yo le agradezco mucho ya
nos quedamos sin tiempo pero este es un
tema al que con seguridad estaremos
volviendo espero yo Próximamente es
Jorge acontece constitucionalista y
doctor en derecho por la universidad de
Sheila que tenga un buen día ustedes
también a nuestros televidentes quédense
con nosotros ya volvemos con más
titulares en directo América
[Música]